good morning and thank you for joining
us for the press conference on the
hundred days of the fund align
Commission president you have the floor
yes thank you so much good morning to
all of you
the College of Commissioner has taken
office now since 100 days and while we
were preparing this meeting here this
morning I thought about the situation
how it was 100 days ago and it's worth
to look back because then you might
remember the topics we're one month
delay will there be a majority for the
college will there be a UK Commissioner
was still the question climate
neutrality 2050 isn't that completely
over ambitious and council will never
agree to that when I started 100 days
ago there were many many different
questions and many difficult issues on
the agenda but the eu-turkey statement
was not under question and in all my
speeches I said that migration will stay
with us migration will not go away and
that we need to find sustainable
solutions and today we are in the middle
of a deep dilemma the events at the
Greek Turkish border clearly point to a
politically motivated pressure on the
--use external border the migrants that
have been brought to the border are in a
situation where they need help and
Greece needs help too and this is one of
the topics I have discussed with Prime
Minister
two attackers over and over and I will
discuss today with president Alderaan so
not just the long-term relationship with
Turkey but also this very acute
situation finding a solution to this
situation will require we leaving the
pressure that is put on the border and
ensuring that the individual right to
ask for asylum is respected and it will
require supporting both Greece and
Turkey to deal with the pressure they
are under and this is why I'm in
constant contact with the Greek Prime
Minister Mitsotakis and I'm meeting
president at one tonight together with
the President of the Council shall
Michel to discuss all these topics on
top of all this we have a situation on
the Greek islands in the refugee camps
that was already over the limit and now
more people are arriving and of course
further support is needed the 350
million euros provided by the European
Union immediately our first step to
improve the situation on the islands
another 350 million euros will follow
but it is urgent to relieve the pressure
on the island by bringing people to the
mainland of the continent - and I think
it is very urgent to care for the
unattended miners on these Greek islands
I'm very concerned about their situation
there are the most vulnerable it's
urgent to get them away from the islands
and to find a safer place for them this
is why last week together with the prime
minister
Mitsotakis I asked the Member States to
help right now of course there will be a
long-term help needed but with help
right now with the unattended miners on
the Greek islands and thankfully we got
positive replies are ready for example
from France from Portugal from
Luxembourg from Finland from Germany
so they will step in
in the acute situation and take on
unattended minors to their countries to
the Member States but of course further
help over time is needed and
humanitarian support for the refugees in
Syria is needed to as a start the
European Union immediately mobilized an
additional 60 million euros but more is
to be done to those who have questions
over the last days the European
capacities I say very clearly that we
are much better prepared in the European
Union today compared to 2015 this is why
we are able to send all this help to
Greece at the moment being but we're
still not prepared enough within these
first 100 days vice-presidents kinas and
Commissioner Aveo Hansen consulted all
the 27 member states to find common
ground for migration and we will put
forward our new European migration pact
right after Easter we're almost done
with it now we are going in depth now in
the preliminary consultations and then
after Easter we'll put it forward
another acute situation that we are
faced with is the Specht of coronavirus
we are of course following closely the
developments in Italy with the
government where the government has
announced new measures to contain the
spread of the buyers we have as you know
within the Commission a corona response
team that is working with the Member
States on the known issues that is
preparedness a risk assessment the
coordination of measures a funding of
research and on Diagnostics on treatment
on vaccines the joint procurement for
example for the protective gear the
spread of the virus has a vast impact on
people's lives but it also has a vast
impact on our economy we are looking
into everything that we can do to help
to address the
effects on the economy there's a strong
coordination ongoing with the leaders of
Europe but also of course with our
European institutions for example like
the ECB or the Euro group to address
these topics in a coordinated and
coherent way in these difficult times we
all sense that people and member states
are asking for more Europe do more act
more act more borders act more migration
support coronavirus the macroeconomic
support yet without a new budget we will
not be able to respond appropriately we
are at the end of the current budget the
seven-year period is almost over and if
I look at the tasks ahead of us we're
running short of the flexibility to act
in crisis as we see them right now so
this is why I call urgently on all
Member States to find now an agreement
on the MFF we needed to proceed it's
very late already and we really need now
a common agreement on the next budget
for the next seven years these were all
unforeseen challenges that we have
addressed immediately but they have not
availed our effort to deliver on our
long term agenda for the European Union
and I remember our first days in office
at that time there was still a lot of
skepticism about the European Green Deal
and the goal to be climate neutral in
2050 today it's no longer the question
if there will be a European Green Deal
or whether the European Union will be
come climate neutral but the question is
how how are we proceeding and how
far-reaching will the transition be
today the European Green Deal is known
to everybody we're working steadily on
this transition like things
as the just transition mechanism or the
climate law that has just been put
forward but many other steps to follow
over the next weeks and month
and 100 days ago there was as I said
initially still the question will we
have a British Commissioner yes or no
well today we know that we've signed the
withdrawal agreement 100 days later we
are rapidly and in unity have adopted a
comprehensive mandate for the
negotiations and we held already the
first round on the negotiations with the
United Kingdom we know what each side is
standing for now and will negotiate for
now we will accompany the implementation
of the withdrawal agreement very
thoroughly this is necessary we are
ready to negotiate a very ambitious and
comprehensive new partnership with the
United Kingdom we will make as much as
we can but the truth is also that our
partnership will be different as it was
before and the UK will be a third
country and the European Union will
continue to forge its path in today's
world on its own after 100 days in the
digital area we have paved the road
already we want to take that what we
want to take for citizens but also a
business and for government on 5g for
example for the very first time the
European Union has a common position and
how to assess security risks and what to
do about them the Commission has
presented its very first white book on
artificial intelligence and the very
first data strategy because we know that
Europe has a huge amount of sleeping
potential of unused data which we can
share in the European data space we want
to create and when I took office the
industry strategy was a long-standing
request by the European Council well
tomorrow on day 101 we will present it
to you it binds together the Green Deal
the Digital Agenda and the global Europe
it combines a strong single market with
competition rules that are fit for the
global economy with the industry
strategy we will sharpen our defensive
instruments globally and at the same
time we will take strong action to tear
down the barriers within the single
market because that's it will enable
business to use the full scale of the
whole single market and at the same time
we're not naive about the global
competition and we're not naive at the
sometimes unfair competition we are
facing and in day 102 so 2 days from
today we will propose a circular economy
action plan this should enable us to
break away with the old model that
consists of taking too much from the
environment from the planet from nature
to consume consume and then waste throw
away but we want to go into a circular
economy that setting is setting up a
full circle of recycling of not taking
more from the planet but giving back to
the planet what we take away in a
completely new model to approach our
economy soon after we took office the
enlargement process was in a deadlock
people in the Western Balkans were
disappointed and we were losing faith in
the European Union now there is a new
perspective also thanks to our balanced
proposal the new methodology which makes
the enlargement process more speedy more
reliable and more credible and our
efforts to help Albania reconstruct
after the devastating earthquake have
gone a long way to restore faith and to
restore trust in the European Union I'm
very often asked about what does it mean
to be geopolitical well whatever I've
explained right now means being
geopolitical and beyond geopolitical
also means going to Africa with the
largest-ever delegation we ever had to a
college to college meeting
this is a real change of mindset we're
working with Africa on a positive agenda
that is looking beyond development and
beyond security we're working on climate
change we work in an environment the
digital transformation skills and job
and many more things we've been
discussing with the African Union when
we was in Addis Abeba we had executive
vice presidents France timmermans
visiting South Africa to discuss green
topics and we have exactly had executive
vice president Margaret West here
discussing the Digital Agenda in Nairobi
this is a new way to working with Africa
and the hrbp Joseph Burrell and
Commissioner Yoruba linemen will present
you to you our new strategy with Africa
in a few moments so over the past 100
days our direction of travel has changed
fundamentally we have spelled out a real
political vision for Europe and a clear
roadmap how to get there
Europe is faced with a huge transition
it's a twin transition of the digital
and the green transition and Europe
needs to ensure its sovereignty and a
complex and geopolitical environment it
was important to grasp the key
underlining driving factors for change
in order to spell out this vision for
the next 30 years we do have together in
Europe we have done so we have developed
a positive agenda for Europe being the
first climate neutral continent first
continent with a data strategy to grasp
the industrial data wave and as of
tomorrow to have a renewed industrial
strategy and a real vision for Europe's
economic and industrial power this all
couldn't have been done without a
fantastic team of commissioners and vice
presidents that are very dedicated
each and every one in their fields in
their fault and I want to thank you
thank them for their dedicated work from
this point on these 100 days were
amazing with them a great team and I'm
happy to answer your questions
thanks I'm Flemming from the Financial
Times
you mentioned the vast impact of
coronavirus and that could be seen on
the economy I wondered if you could give
us some more details in terms of what
the Commission believes is needed now on
the budgetary response on an EU wide
scale the Eurogroup is obviously meeting
next week as is echo firm how large a
coordinated fiscal stimulus do you now
believe is needed by member states in
order to deal with what some economists
are now saying is a serious risk of a
recession thank you so we do have two
different approaches that are possible
the one is flexibility and the other one
is money indeed and the Commission is in
close contact of course with the
national authorities with the industry
representatives and other stakeholders
on the macroeconomic side I am in
constant close contact with Christine
Lagarde - and indeed we are preparing
for the finance finance minister meeting
that will take place next week to
discuss the situation and the possible
actions at the EU level we're exploring
all the existing possibilities for
flexibilities for example in the
stability and growth pact and what state
aid is concerned for exceptional
circumstances within this frame and of
course there is a strong coordination of
our answers and action at all levels and
these are not only the national levels
and the EU levels but also on the levels
beyond
you valentino what's next I will inform
the Wall Street Journal I president them
here you were saying that a hundred days
ago the eu-turkey statement was not in
question so I guess the question is is
it is the you turkey statement currently
in question and what is your target for
this meeting with President or the one
he has been calling for more money and I
realized that the EU countries are
currently negotiations on the NFF so
doubling or coming up with the new but
with a new envelope for Turkey might be
difficult but is this part of your
strategy to sort of hint that you might
renew the eu-turkey segment in terms of
financial means thank you well tonight
is the restart of a dialogue the
rekindle of speaking together and this
is the beginning this is very important
this is the beginning of having the
dialogue and developing at best a common
roadmap this is certainly will not be
done today of course we will speak of
topics like stability in the region and
here it is for me very important that
there is a clear consensus on reducing
the tension and the pressure on the
Greek Turkish border you know that there
is the obligation to protect the border
that is EU law but there's also the
obligation to guarantee fundamental
rights including the right to ask for
asylum so this is in the Charter and
this is what we need as a solution and
the very end that the actual situation
the tension is reduced the migrants get
help that are at the Turkish border but
of course the scope of the discussion
tonight will be wider it's not only
stability in the region
and security and migration but of course
the scope will also be on questions like
for example Syria and we will go through
the different topics that are part of
the relationship between Turkey and the
European Union so step-by-step look at
what the one side and the other side's
point of view is and figure out how we
can move forward in a more positive way
as it has been over the last week thank
you thanks for your active also two
questions the first one when you met
President Trump in Davos you promised
that there will be an agreement ideal
even in few weeks time between the EU
and the US so I would like to know when
at least a proposal to trump president
Rome will be ready and therefore when
you plan to travel to the United States
and secondly you have to deal with the
most fragmented Parliament in the
history also you have to deal with I
mean big divisions between the Member
States and you promised a lot of
dialogue and we seen a lot of public
consultations and the postponement of
legislative proposals so have you seen
any progress in bringing together and
building this unity over the past
hundred days
so first your first question what
President Trump is concerned we had a
good meeting in Davos we agreed to work
on possible a trade agreement to look
into the possibilities for example not
only in trade but also an energy for
example or in new technologies we have
ongoing consultations back and forth
visits on both sides of the Atlantic so
I would qualify it at the moment being
as work in progress and the moment we
are done then indeed there will be a
visit to the United States but it's work
in progress
your second question is children on the
Parliament well there is always the
notion out there that this is
a fragmented Parliament I don't see it
like this I see it as a very lively
interested Parliament with whom I think
it's it's it's the typical symbol for
vivid democracy to have these different
opinions and to have a very constant
dialogue with all the different groups
and as you know I always do that
whenever we have the parliamentary
session since past work or this week
here in Brussels and for me it's
enormous ly+ to have these different
standpoints because then you can shape
your agenda we have a strong common
vision on the goals but how to reach
these goals of course you have to shape
your agenda accordingly to what the
learning effects are we are doing
together a new field what the move
towards climate neutral continent is
concerned or for example on the whole
topic of the Digital Agenda and for me
it's fascinating it's very positive to
have the exchange with this Parliament
thank you we had a colleague on the Left
yes
you
almost manifest and allostery story for
president element forgive dodge any
staff CMS event current situation the
mean daring the kinder often insulin
this is problem mister nist SP can't set
decrease and the turkish cohesion grant
safer Ganganagar housekeeper missing
canton getting tails at film young
we're talking a business degree usually
gear on which the Fifth Circuit does the
field in hundred million and and he'll
scaled under FIFA vendor de la Garza
bomb alarmed him any criteria for
argit's business under tongue era
president just hospitaiity the stain
when an eland tideland tried to be
fleeced and thousand him from that
kinder in a NASA fought action as Jesus
attached on her house to bring us is in
fury in logon almond torte Assange
beaten monsters are under a lender
sister and Petaling East as NIST and any
SS leftist a that's when it sweaty
froggy is yet feel from truck of
temptation president aired or an
indecent to some and anguish problem
van Viet nu Commission order art reflect
any immediate slander truck of the
creatures of the creature guild muffin
on DC 2ch tender entry
alpha the metal to be in Lancashire as I
switched it that's the pass we are
unwilling that was to listen on the
incident of thin tradition in zone sofa
basin and as resistors
Schmidt a lot huffed commands I'm with
him premiere-minister
desireth Garber undergone been met him
before ends after flick of the actually
take it yet smooth basket ambien on the
establish failure of the UN but light at
noon Minda hearing Kindle and you
nutrition the often engines and there's
a public let's the Vltava mega baton is
a apart martyrs limited start a coup
tearful who brings air tank bomb does
the reaction becomes invited Adebisi
Havana of not common Abba naturally camp
directors belong hostage and process of
outbound most myth implicates of the UN
but light illumination
does
via Zeus tomato sonsoo fallacy the
vessel can endure C and visual noise so
how's done aha thus obtained when I
inspired him stricken I'm process
commands I'm at UNICEF that's where rich
dish cooked Oviatt are bitin beacon via
constant as old as venom but lighter to
human leisure dot in the in camps and
Oda Abba come just via an mission is
most harm does music women want a sea
water and Dawa have the perspectiva Dan
Harmon and thus food fly fighter to
fight and hog business e the Eichner in
the Hassan's and the Turkish tradition
cancer on the continued in the nest
antagonism we smell of the on the right
artist about Optum their talk i the over
patient Venson sign of old age negative
not had to iron as it was shown Burford
the volvió
here in price one Smith Allah cuffed the
moon mission does the reader were on
phonetic at on filing he'll for Freddy
indignity dot and Turkish magician
fences and become dust gate nor in de
mohamed iron Batali's misogynist is a
walled area
minister-president on Shaba door exact
of thus
near antagonism hillford EDLP show onion
life that we of available that's the
concert station register about on whom
the zest fear not super hurt after
stretched of as real as a percentage of
the squash bridge president Alwyn
Vova I know that Anakin thus yeah the
talk I feel I stood in Dame's if mirror
a million fletchling
Zod alpha drones are here our primary
Tokai food is a the floor knocked our
deathbeds whitens the ocular of the
verbal information does
that's Leslie I'm Leslie Vonn in
Dagenham Azusa Trudeau who owned off on
des via mid and under I know
gocbar alpha iron barroom and veganism
does ensue conferred so I shall
escalation under Turkish appreciation
fanciful Indian thank you very much
James will be next thank you it's James
Chris from a telegraph two quick
questions do you think there will be a
landing zone for the brexit talks in a
hundred days time in June without
compromise on the EU mandate and
secondly on Greece and Turkey how much
more are you willing to pay turkey to
keep migrants out of Europe well I think
if I start with the second question
first already twice now describe the
process that will start tonight this is
the dialogue that we are rekindling and
this covers all the topics also the
question how are we after the eu-turkey
agreement basically the commitments are
fulfilled
so either had they have the money has
been paid or it has already been
contracted that we asked ourselves how
will be the next step be but this is at
the very beginning and it's a wider
scope that we have to take including
also the question how to deal with the
situation in Syria and the questions I
just answered before though please take
into account this is the beginning of
the talks that we were starting tonight
on brexit well I think now we both have
set our negotiation presented our
negotiation mandate you know that we
want to be very ambitious we want to
have a very good relationship with our
British friends we are aware that there
are differences in the approach towards
what scope should the future agreement
have and what are if I may say so the
rules of the games
everybody has to abide to so it will be
different different it will be important
that the United Kingdom kind of makes up
its mind the closer they want to have
the access to the single market the more
of course they have to play by the rules
that are the rules of the single market
if this is not the UK's choice then of
course there will be more distant and it
will be more difficult for the UK to
access the single market so I think it's
up to the United Kingdom within this
negotiations to to think about the
trade-offs they want to take into
account both of yours Nieminen Jamuna
D'ass filet mignon owned a company whose
LED cruise sank PU first compensated of
the Dijon gassy upon a scoop winds on
the pristine mineralized a leopard
sandpaper te
not on take CP who's on it disappeared
wanna scoop on cyclic overheated lady on
the mean says Montes could only planned
on the chef dog anesthesia dishes on the
camasta he don't let that go addition
sick on the question on the finances I
was already very clear that we are at
the beginning and
no numbers are being discussed at the
various part but this is something which
has to be seen in the overall picture we
firm to your question how I see the
Turkish EU statement well I think that
in general it is a good construction
because it is shared responsibilities it
has a mechanism that makes clear and
this is important that irregular
migration is not something that is
tolerated but in response that
humanitarian corridors
so taking Syrian refugees from Turkey to
the European Union is the way to choose
so if you look at the numbers so we've
seen that there have been tenfold more
people that came from Turkey in the
humanitarian corridor to the European
Union than have been returned from the
Greek island to Turkey and the second
point which i think is a fair one is the
fact that the European Union supports
for example the Syrian refugees in
Turkey with turkeys taken care of in
health matters in education matters in
housing and other topics as we've done
1.7 million Syrian refugees have been
supported by the European Union by the
eu-turkey statement so these general
principles are good ones but of course
the this this agreement of this
statement has been taken for a limited
amount of time so now we have to discuss
to discuss a broader broader scope
well last week we started to call for
support what the unaccompanied minors is
concerned indeed some member states and
I'm very grateful for that or reacted
immediately I think it's a measure that
of respect that they published their own
numbers so what the capacities at the
moment are being concerned I'm gonna be
in Greece on Thursday on this matter
so by then we certainly will have a
better overview also what the Greek side
has to report thank you thanks Dana
David Harrison Horn with Politico
president Wunderland on coronavirus
we've seen very different responses by
member states including some limits on
solidarity with Italy's requests through
the civil protection mechanism some
member states banning the export of
protective equipment and this seems not
because there are different facts on the
ground but despite different facts on
the ground showing needs are greater in
some parts of the EU than others does
the EU have sufficient authority to
address this crisis are there additional
authorities neither and then more
broadly on your first hundred days on
health issues or migration or virtually
any other issue are you observing that
the mechanisms the levers that the EU
has to address crises are sufficient
that you have sufficient cooperation
from the Capitals you mentioned your
frustration with the MFF or do you see
areas for improvement in how crises are
addressed and how decisions are taken in
the EU first of all it was a very good
to set up the Karuna crisis response
team in the Commission because as we saw
the speed in which the the situation
progressed it was necessary to address
many different work strands and from
the Commissioner to the for the economy
Paulo jauntily dental unit to the
commission of her health and many others
Stella Peoria leaders it was necessary
to have this coherent and comprehensive
approach we meet once a week in this
setting under my leadership to have the
full overview about what the the focus
at the moment is and where we have to
act or react faster what cooperation
between member states is concerned I
want to thank the Member States and the
Commissioner for the speed at which they
found regular mechanism to meet and to
communicate but of course this was
necessary because indeed at the very
beginning it was rather bumpy
therefore now I see with a lot of
satisfaction that they're well
established procedures there's a clear
communication there's a clear overview
about the different measures that have
to be taken not every decision in every
member state is an identical one without
any question but the coordination and
the communication between the 27 member
states themselves with the Commission is
working as smoothly now and very
efficient if you ask for the next time
or for the crisis mechanisms well its
own always difficult to predict what the
next crisis will be we will be in as I
said initially 2015 migration and today
no comparison we've learned a lot we've
improved a lot but we haven't gone the
hallway we still need the migration pact
so without any question but we would not
never ever have been able to react that
fast in Greece if there wouldn't have
been improvements and coronavirus i
think we have to
strengthen ac/dc I'm grateful that I
hear from member states that they want
to strengthen ac/dc - it's necessary
obviously this brings me back to mff it
needs to be visible in the MFF but there
are other crises that will come but we
do not know of at the moment being what
kind of crisis this will be and
therefore in general I see it as a task
for us the Commission to always be ready
to answer with well established patterns
on crisises Korona
is a typical by a typical example where
we're able to do that we took patterns
that were in place for other crises put
them together and moved forward so we
will not know what the next crisis will
look like thank you sorry Griselda was
next
ooh resale deposit or de la radio
spaniel hacer maxi Syrian Antonia covers
Opilio - da da Zilla andreas Mississippi
see you said Clayton Kershaw struck
Assad even a reality see Syria no
shanshu companion color situation we try
complex me Shammi come Lysander near le
avian Santa Mozilla chocolate waffle de
menthe oh uh travelers vadas ill et
subsidiary
our security Jimmy reservoir civil
nuclear power in exception threatened
were supposed Avenue in normal an evil
opium Yakushima reservoir pourquoi the
reaction dollar Commission a committee
visit shoulder to a fundamental Avenue
to it Antonio visitor Sheila Guardian do
treaty yes once again I want to
emphasize that European borders must be
protected yes this is European law as I
said and fundamental rights must be
protected and respected this is in the
charter of the European Union and both
has to go hand in hand and this is the
reason why tonight there is the meeting
will president other one this is the
reason why I've been in constant contact
with a prime minister Mitsotakis
this is the reason why we try hard to
reduce the tension and to mitigate the
difficulties that we have at the moment
being to have progress to find a
solution that that brings us back to a
situation as we want
thank you next case gurgi it's a hook
result as question I still don't get it
does Greece according to the Commission
needs to grant asylum to those people we
see on TV footage at the border yes or
no and okay if the answer is yes
is it is it easy
yes I mean Germany has said it closes
its borders Austria said it closes
Hizballah Hungary said it closed
involves why should Greece open its
borders it was the first of all to
answer your first question and then your
second question so the right to ask for
asylum is a fundamental right and it has
to be respected so then the second point
is it was the Turkish president who said
the European borders are open they are
not open they were not open and they are
not open and therefore we have to start
to talk between the conflicting parties
to find a solution that this what we saw
over the last weekend will not happen
again
we are already progressing but we are
not at the point where we want people
thank you very much yes please go ahead
hi Maria automatic Europa back in 2015
as a minister of defense you criticize
Hungary for using tear gas against a
saloon seeker
you said and I quote this is not
acceptable and it is against European
rules so now a my skin is it legal
unacceptable the use of tear gas by
Greece and the shots of robber but it's
against a seeker simple as a principle
or responses must be proportionate
alleged violence incidences need to be
investigated and excessive use of force
is unacceptable this is a standing
principle thank you very much my
colleague in front
yes thank you Laura costume from the
German television ard I have also a
question on the meeting today with
President aired one and I would like to
ask my question in German service in T
concrete and for the woman the president
add one height a bump - often Tish ly
good metric in concrete form president
add one count does Vivian
not niched miss de estas were higher
aren't the India Luke we - Dalton the
for communist and the Turkish leaders
and when survivin una tight leash on
dolphins is nice Twitter horn on their
services from sophistica frescoes plays
after him Ali Zeidan su Hearn a lagoon -
nutrition standpoint of the opposition
leader for ensign alone Tajikistan
filter off to hone on commands I'm super
she noticed a beginning harmed vivia
midst a fogger of the film looked linger
in debt talk I owned a understood
synthetic I for the albeit dizzy toot of
orange I think on this begin Toyota arms
especially enjoyed armed a brushless
ensign so none that we had enough a he
pleasure Croatia of an innocent one tag
on one start Finland
thank you very much we're going to take
the last question and it's going to go
there
good morning Matthew Newman from M Lex
president I was intrigued by your
comments about the EU no longer being
naive when looking at the global
competition and I understand that part
of the industrial policy will be about
reciprocity
just wanted to ask if you can give a
little bit of more details about how you
might enforce that if a country is not
playing by fair rules in terms of public
procurement and then on just coming back
to your home nation in Lufthansa is
suffering like many airlines from the
drop in demand from the coronavirus and
they look to be asking for government
aid to help the workers who are staying
at home and help pay for that that would
that be what you were just mentioning
before about exceptional circumstances
regarding state aid is that a good
example of how you might think that the
Commission should react speak for a
single example because this is to look
at what are exceptional circumstances is
a process that has to be done and
not at first hand view but what you're
referring to is called sabai toggled so
this is something which is has been used
by Germany very successfully during the
last financial crisis the principle is
that the workers are or the employees
are kept in the company even if there's
not enough work to do have additional
training and the company doesn't have to
pay the whole salary but the the
uninsurance the the unemployment
insurance does provide the necessary or
fill the necessary gap to have a whole
salary which has as a positive effect
that the employees stay in the company
the knowledge is kept and improved in
the company the moment the market is
picking up again
there are capacities to answer the needs
of the market and the employees have a
stable income so the the consume at home
is kept up - same goes for pension
payments and the insurances insurance
payments that are ongoing so this is a
principle that has helped a lot what the
general state aid is concerned there
indeed we will use all the necessary and
possible flexibilities for these
exceptional circumstances at the moment
being we are coordinating among the
European institutions to define then
very clearly and very precise what it
works for what the industry strategy is
concerned indeed you're right
that we have to fight for a level
playing field around the world and
indeed this is one of the issues that is
being tackled in the industry strategy
that will be presented tomorrow to look
into the foreign subsidies indeed the
lack of reciprocity on public
procurement or the potential race to the
bottom on
and so the the basic principle on
reciprocity is if we allow others to
compete here on our market of course we
expect that the reciprocity is given
that our companies can of course compete
for example for public tenders in the
other country - otherwise we have to
take measures thank you very much you
may wish to stay for the press
conference on Africa which will start in
a few minutes thank you very much again